i admire your courage miss uh trench
soviet trench i admire your luck
mr bond
james bond
not only is the name iconic you see what
i did there it was a lot of fun
it's one of the greatest lines in action
movie history
bond jimmy bond i'm sorry i just don't
find myself worthy of saying
the actual name of double o seven as a
matter of fact
only six men in the history of the
universe have had the honor
of playing the legendary super spy james
bond
some are still acting some enjoying
their golden years and some have passed
on
but for today's show we're bringing them
all out of retirement for
one last mission should they choose to
accept it
oh right that's the uh that's the other
one what are you talking about
this is not gonna end well today we'll
figure out once and for all
or at least until the next movie comes
out who is the greatest bond in
cinematic history
the gold bond if you will vying for the
title of a
medicated powder is the o.g the late
great sean connery his immediate
successor george lazenby
the always classy roger moore staging
screen veteran timothy dalton the
piercing blue eyes of mr brosnan
and the rough and tumble daniel craig
all turned in stellar performances as
james bond in their day but i only have
one martini to hand out
the rest gets a split a case of
milwaukee's best
white here's how we'll determine a
winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash
audience score round three villains
and then we'll do a wild card round that
sean connery hopes will involve chest
hair
the daring adventures the smooth veneer
the magic with the ladies
i have none of that and those that can't
do judge
let's get it on round one
box office a new james bond flick
opening at your local movie theater has
been a big deal since 1962
when mr connery first appeared as
double07 in dr no
sure we're excited to see the villains
the bond ladies the musical number and
the opening credits
but it's the suave secret agent that
gets our wallets out
and if you're gonna win this round
volume helps so apologies to george
lazenby and timothy dalton they'll be
fighting an uphill battle
throughout this episode as they only
have three bond films to share between
them
but it's worth noting that both averaged
over a hundred million dollars for their
films at the domestic box office
and worldwide george lassenby's loan
outing his bond in on her majesty's
secret service
raked in 563 million dollars
dalton's two films the living daylights
and license to kill averaged
370 million dollars across the globe
well done lads
but now it's time for the big boys
pierce brosnan and daniel craig each
have four bond films to their credit
although craig's fifth is on its way any
day now month now
year now the fellas are too thin nail
here in the states with craig enjoying a
257 million dollar to brazil's 243
million dollar average
overseas it's an easier victory for
craig as he tops
all james bonds by averaging 900 million
dollars
every time he walks into frame and does
that cool turn
shoot maneuver that i wasn't allowed to
do because they don't trust me with
weapons or even martinis around this
studio
well you give it your best shot perhaps
the two men best known for bond
are sir connery and sir more in part
because they each played the role
seven times yes we are counting sean's
return to the character for 1983's
never say never again hello again
and while indiana jones pops can't quite
get to daniel craig's worldwide average
he still earns an easy silver medal in
that event with 757 million
dollars for his average that's well
above rogers still excellent
614 million dollar per film total it's
actually here in the us of a that sean
connery fully asserts his dominance
whereas roger moore's flicks took in a
respectable 180 million dollar average
connery clears the entire field by
almost 100 million dollars as his movies
rang up 365 million bucks
each and every time he was on the poster
for kicks
let's see if any bond films vaulted over
the mythological
one billion dollar mark uh yeah they did
three accomplished that feat skyfall was
the all-time
king with 1.2 billion dollars edging out
the two connery flicks to run past the
bill
goldfinger and thunderball connery got
there when the canvas was fresh
and what a portrait he painted craig and
more proved to be competitive but when
it comes to bond making money at the
movies
except no substitutes sean connery wins
round one
and goes up one to nothing to nothing
to nothing to nothing look there's five
fellas on the scoreboard folks it's
gonna take a while
shocking positively shocking
round two tomato meter slash audience
score sure
money is what i want but you can't buy
me love the tomato meter doesn't care
how rich you are
it values what's on the inside are you a
good movie
sometimes whole new ball game in this
round and even george lassenby can be a
threat
again he only made one bond movie but
it's quality over quantity here
and on her majesty's secret service gets
him
all the way up to 80 percent on the
tomato meter
gentlemen dan anyone beat that it's a
tight contest here as all but one bond
actor enjoy a fresh average on said
tomato meter
poor roger moore is i can't even say
rotten he's almost fresh he's fresh at
jason
he averages 56.8 percent but he's still
looking up at pierce brosnan at 61
timothy dalton at 74.5 percent daniel
craig at 78.7 percent lassenby with his
eighty percent once again
and on top oh that's the way i like it
is sean connery with 83 percent
apologies to connor and his family for
that impression
so wait is the scottish fella from darby
oh gill and the little people just going
to crush everyone in this round too
that not so fast connery's best
individual flicks are impressive with
goldfinger topping
all bond films at 98 percent but
every actor who put on the tux has at
least one movie in the tomato meter top
10.
daniel craig's best is casino royale at
95 percent
lassenby has his entry at 80 percent
roger moore has the spy who loved me at
79 percent
appears brosnan's golden eyes it's 78
it's a great movie it is a better video
game
precisely and timothy dalton sneaks in
with license to kill
at 77 it's a bleaker picture for
brosnan and roger moore at the bottom
they each have three
movies in the six most rotten bond
pictures but hey we did what we had to
do to get denise richards a role
as a literal rocket scientist
speaking of giving the crowd what they
want let's move over to the audience
score
once again it's roger moore bringing up
the rear but this time pierce brosnan
joins him in just
south of freshville dalton and lazubi
are on the fresh dance floor but can
barely hear the music and so once again
it's daniel craig and sean connery
duking it out at the top
and it's the most recent still current
bond that comes out ahead
with his collection of four movies
sitting at 73.5 percent
edging out connery's seven flicks at 70
percent
it's often mentioned that daniel craig
has made two great bond films casino
royale and skyfall
and then two other bond movies but those
good ones are
great and they're both in the top three
of the audience score
sandwiching goldfinger sounds delicious
but no time to eat now
daniel craig wins his first round and we
got us a ball game
i'm sorry that last hand nearly killed
me
round three dylan sure james bond gets
the mgm
roaring lions share of the credit but
his films are made
exponentially more entertaining by the
presence of badass ladies like [ __ ]
galore
tracy bond and wylyn as well as the
subject of this round
the villains yeah if liver cirrhosis
doesn't kill 07
one of these all-time baddies just might
but which bond faced off against the
evilist of the evil
[Music]
uh sorry doc not this time [ __ ]
in this category even one dynamic
villain could be enough to turn the tide
in your favor
just ask rick sanchez the bad guy from
timothy dalton's the living
daylights haven't heard of him he's the
one that feeds
people to sharks and if you got more
screen time maybe he to figure out a way
to give them improved freaking laser
beams
throw me a freaking bone here that's
your clubhouse leader
but here comes george lazidby going up
against maybe the toughest bonfo
ever blofeld played by telly savalas
blofeld set the template for a thinking
person's evildoer
matching not just wits but brains
against jimmy
his legacy was reinvigorated when
christoph waltz portrayed an updated
version
going up against daniel craig in his
multiple bond flicks
it's a chess game where the nefarious
genius always seems two steps ahead
and maybe that's because craig could
barely recover from another great bad
dude with a physical defect
the blood weeping washif played by mads
mikkelsen
is he related to phil anybody uh had
that answer how was his short game
that's it but if you want a treasure
trove of sin
head over to the 1970s and revisit the
roger moore era
not only was christopher lee an amazing
devious presence in star wars
lord of the rings and dracula his turn
as
francisco scaramanga and the man with
the golden gun
legitimizes an otherwise rather silly
double-oh-seven entry
yapfit kodo's mr big and christopher
watkins max
zorin we're also memorable but it's
richard keel's
jaws that makes more a potent threat to
take this round
the metal mouth seemingly indestructible
yet surprisingly emotional nerdwell
appeared in both the spy who loved me
and moonraker
and just might take the trophy for bond
villain that we're secretly pulling for
kinda i know he's bad but he's
irresistible
here's to us sean connery will make some
noise here as well as his bond film
goldfinger is the rare double duty doozy
of being both a movie title
and a villain do you expect me to talk
no mr bond i expect you to die we also
got odd job in that classic but it was
the original bond movie that set the
template for baddies
so deviant we named the flick after them
dr no catapulted movie antagonist to new
eccentric heights and set the trend for
the elaborate dress
plans and evil layers a unique feat of
engineering if i may say so i designed
it myself
but if you're like me and love jaws no
no not you we're talking about the movie
now
possibly your favorite bonfire is red
grant played by quint himself
robert shaw not only does he make from
russia with love one of the most
enjoyable spy movies ever
esquire ranked him as the best bond
baddie in history
connery also squared off against the
original incarnation of blofeld
played by donald pleasance but to me
this round belongs to roger moore's
unique array of villains that boast
diversity of thought
tactics intelligence and quirks unless
pierce brosnan wants to swoop in what no
small talk
no chitchat he does make a case with
goldeneye as both sean beam and famica
janssen make terrific villains but after
that
as much as i love jonathan price the bad
guys just can't compete
this round belongs to roger moore's 007
and now our tie at the top
is a three-way how original
what will they think of next and now
it's time for our wild card round
gadgets yep that's right it's the round
that throws a monkey into the wrench
a twist into the fate and a shake into
the martini
which bond is bringing the best gadgets
to his mission
every double 07 film features tons of
fun technological toys
so i'll stick with each player's very
best of the best these are my
favorite gaggle of gadgets from the one
and only q shout out to the late great
desmond lewin who portrayed the role of
bond's genius sidekick the most
and to john cleese and hugh dancy who've
made the role their own since
all right let's explode some pens
this might be the only round where sean
connery is at somewhat of a disadvantage
because his golden bond years were back
in the 1960s
however he still gets to show off some
gear that would make boba fett blush
look at this jetpack in thunderball i'm
also a fan of the cigarette gun but both
those things are dangerous kids
from you only lived twice and a suitcase
that probably inspired that mariachi
from desperado
in from russia with love roger moore's
avant-garde 70s approach to both his
fashion
and tech upped the ante as we were
introduced to everything from
a wrist gun to a bug detecting shaver
you know for those hard hard-to-reach
places where you might have
bugs but if i'm highlighting one
technological marvel from moore's run
it's a watch they can also be a saw
oh and did we mention it's a rolex yeah
go back and revisit live and let die
now i like the guns n roses version over
paul mccartney's hot take
but there is no way to improve upon a
wristwatch that can also help you
build a deck good luck replicating that
one
apple pierce brosnan scores some major
points for his golden eye exploding pen
but in his later films the gadgets tried
a little too hard to pay homage to the
goofier 70s
so this is where they keep the old
relics in eh
we had a disappearing car the x-ray
glasses it was fun
do not get me wrong but it also made
clear that this bond iteration was only
going to get
sillier and more ridiculous even as
pierce did his best to add legitimacy to
the zaniness surrounding him
so exit remington steel and enter layer
cake
are you expecting an exploding pen
we don't really go in for that anymore
daniel craig's double 07 relied as much
on his fists
and the occasional head butt as much as
any previous super spy
but he still had some clutch gadgetry
that helped literally keep him alive
the defibrillator narrowly avoided his
death in his very first 007 outing
we also saw a sweet explosive keychain
which is classic bond
and then inspector we saw some
scientific tomfoolery
with the smart blood also let's not
overlook the return of the aston martin
in
skyfall people lost their minds in the
theater when it was revealed
even me who questionably prefers pierce
brosnan's zippy bmw z3 from goldeneye
after that movie came out it became the
midlife crisis car to lease
move over mazda miata there's a new tiny
sheriff in town
the bmw z3 perfect for saving the world
from evil geniuses
and run by fruiters every bun has a cool
car
great gadgets and fists of fury
including george lazenby
who will unfortunately take an l in this
round simply due to the lack of a tech
resume this never happened to the other
fella but what his one movie lacks in
geek squad know-how
he makes up for with actual fighting
ability
his martial arts on the beach and on her
majesty's secret service are impressive
so maybe he didn't care about the more
modern toys folks who do their yoga
claim their body's a temple
lazenby's bond body was a gadget and he
wielded it with
vengeance that leaves timothy dalton who
would seem to be limited by his mere two
films in the world of double 07
but those flicks came out in the 1980s
and thus presented the best mixture of
classic bond gadget necessity with
futuristic tech ridiculousness
his aston martin comes standard with a
rocket launcher
and he also has a ride that could ski
down mountains plus
every great vehicle needs an exploding
key fob and his license to kill
signature gun is pure
unfiltered 007 mythology dalton ended up
turning down a contract extension after
a pro-owned legal battle over the rights
to james bond movies
but his two entries added so much to the
bond gadget portfolio that we wanted to
see more
and in the end that's enough to get him
a surprise win in the wild card round
meaning it's a one to one to one to zero
tie whoever she was must have scared the
living daylights out of her
hell of an effort by all six gentlemen
an honorable mention
goes to the 1967 casino royale star
david niven george lazenby came into a
tough position
as he followed a legend in the making in
sean connery but he adjudicated himself
well
and kept the franchise afloat for roger
moore to come in and give us the next
great
era and props to pierce whose goldeneye
may be one of the most important films
in the entire legacy of bond
without his name power and the vintage
bond feel of that movie
we may not be referring to double 07 as
a present day force at the cinemas
but lazambi and brosnan couldn't muster
quite enough to win a round today
so now my decision for the winner works
between connery
moore dalton and craig and speaking of
rounds
let's make grown-up hydration the
tiebreaker our own expert researcher
mark hoffmeyer
who i would say is the cue of this show
except he looks much better in a suit
than i do
referred me to the economist who broke
down all the on-camera drinks
james bond has consumed the most
exercise liver of the bunch goes to
daniel craig with 22 total cocktails
connery is second with 16 and more
follows closely
with 14. and for me i want my bond's
brain to be well lubricated but also
sober enough to
pull off the mission which is why sean
connery
is still my ultimate james bond
we only lost him recently but he got a
head start on everyone else
and never looked back so
do you lose as gracefully
as you win i wouldn't know i've never
lost it's connery's mix of masculine
suave
rough handsomeness and pitch perfect one
liners that sealed the deal for me
some of the content in his era hasn't
aged all that well but mr connery in the
suit
is timeless unlike this vid which could
be outdated as soon as i see daniel
craig's last stand
as double07 maybe he returns to skyfall
form
in which case i'd have to return to the
studio and rent this from
men's warehouse again to reconsider my
take
so while that keeps me up at night we
leave it to you dear viewer to weigh in
on the subject and let us know
your favorite bond of all time you can
hit me up anytime at mark ellis live
and while you're at it show mi6 that you
care by
subscribing to rotten tomatoes on
youtube and checking out
rottentomatoes.com
thanks for watching and i do believe
it's time for me to also have a drink
that is shaken not stirred in which case
i'll then have to clean up all the coors
light that explodes out of the can
you